finn a résumé cet entretien inédit avec
son homologue américain on va tout de
suite retrouvé
antoine claireaux en direct de genève
antoine vous avez particulièrement vous
suivi la conférence de presse de
vladimir poutine que doit-on retenir ce
soir
oui tout à fait stéphanie je me trouvais
même dans cette salle de conférence oui
stéphanie je vous trouvez donc je me
trouvais donc dans cette salle de
conférence lorsque va dire poutine s'est
exprimé et dès la première question on
est rentré dans le vif du sujet d'une
façon de façon très concrète dans les
relations entre les etats-unis et la
russie avec cette question sur le retour
des ambassadeurs et venir poutine l'a
confirmé ce retour des ambassadeurs aura
bien lieu d'ici un ou deux jours juste
pour des questions techniques donc
l'ambassadeur en poste normalement en
russie l'ambassadeur américain en russie
reviendra de même que l'ambassadeur
américain retournera à moscou et s'est
considéré c'était considéré en amont de
ceux de ce sommet comme une véritable
avancée ces désordres et c'est désormais
chose faite je vous propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine sur ce sujet
concernant le retour des ambassadeurs à
leur place habituelle de travail à
moscou et washington
nous sommes convenus que cette question
est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
l'horreur ambassadeurs respectifs demain
ou après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain
ils vont entamer des consultations sur
l'ensemble
notre interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes j'ai eu l'impression que les
deux parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions
oui mon confrère olivier l'a évoqué il
ya tout juste quelques minutes les deux
hommes ont longuement longuement
travaillé sur la question de la
cybersécurité de lanières poutine estime
qu'il ya de véritables possibilités de
coopération sur ce sujet entre les deux
pays la preuve des consultations au plus
haut niveau au plus haut niveau vont
avoir lieu entre les deux pays et coûté
concernant la cybersécurité nous avons
convenu d'entamer des consultations à ce
sujet c'est selon moi extrêmement
important maintenant qu'ils devraient
prendre quelle obligation
je veux vous informer de choses qui sont
généralement connus mais pas par le
grand public
de source américaine j'ai juste peur de
me tromper dans le nom de l'organisation
mais baissent comme vous le transmettra
plus tard il ressort de source
américaine que le plus grand nombre de
cyber attaques dans le monde sont
effectués à partir du cyberespace
américain en deuxième place se trouve le
canada puis il y a deux pays d'amérique
latine et enfin la grande bretagne la
russie ne fait pas partie de cette liste
de pays à partir desquels le plus grand
nombre de cyber attaques de toutes
sortes sont effectués comme vous pouvez
le constater c'est la première chose
deuxièmement en 2020 nous avons reçu dix
demandes des etats-unis concernant des
cyber attaques visant des
infrastructures américaines comme le
disent nos collègues depuis le
cyberespace russe et il y a deux
demandes de ce genre cette année à
toutes ces demandes l'année dernière et
cette année nos collègues ont reçu des
réponses exhaustives à son tour la
russie a envoyé 45 demandes de ce type à
l'organisation concernés aux états unis
l'année dernière et au premier semestre
de cette année 35
nous n'avons reçu pour l'instant aucune
réponse
l'ukraine est également un dossier qui a
été largement évoquée par les deux
hommes l'ukraine et sa possible adhésion
à l'otan qui serait une ligne rouge à ne
pas franchir pour le kremlin mais aussi
le conflit dans l'est du pays vladimir
poutine a rappelé tout son attachement
aux accords de minsk et il a fait savoir
que c'était également le cas de joe
biden écoutez concernant nos engagements
vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
nous avons un seul engagement contribuer
à la réalisation des accords de mise
comme si que la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire on va entamer cette
voie sans aucun doute je porte votre
attention sur le fait que novembre
dernier la délégation ukrainienne nous a
adressé ses estimations sur sa leur
vision des accords de minsk
il parle de l'intégration politique du
temps basse dans le système politique
ukrainien et dans la constitution
ukrainienne a donc il faut apporter des
amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne
alors bien entendu de nombreux autres
thématiques ont été abordées entre les
deux hommes
on peut entre autres ont entre autres
distinguer le dossier and have any
largement évoquée par les journalistes
américains et britanniques présents dans
la salle va dire poutine en réponse à
dénoncer le fait que son organisation
appelé à des manifestations illégales et
appelé des mineurs a participé à ces
à ses angles à ces manifestations ce qui
constitue ce qui est illégal tout
simplement en russie mais de façon
générale il ressort de cette de cette de
cette conférence de presse et de ce
sommet une impression positive une
impression que le dialogue est possible
entre les etats-unis et la russie alors
lanières poutine l'a encore rappelé lors
de cette conférence de presse il n'y
avait pas d'hostilité dans ces
pourparlers même si bien entendu il y
avait de nombreuses divergences ce
sommet constitue donc que tout le monde
l'espère une première étape dans les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis web merci antoine gayraud en direct
de genève et plusieurs invités nous
accompagnent ce soir pour le côté
décryptage olivier d'ozon et ceis
consultant en relations internationales
bonsoir olivier d'ozon merci d'être avec
nous rôle garner un professeur de
politique internationale à l'université
américaine de paris on va revenir vers
vous dans quelques minutes pour faire un
détour par ce plateau je suis ravi de
retrouver un invité en chaîne annonce
sur ce plateau au clos d'un
blanchemaison merci à toi d'être avec
nous avant de retourner à genève un
faire un détour voir l'aspect américain
le décryptage de ce discours de joe
biden vadimir poutine plutôt chaleureux
c'était une rencontre constructive pour
lui
franche et directe constructive précises
concrètes
il a utilisé plusieurs adjectifs
peut-être on pourra l'utiliser un autre
très professionnelle c'est à dire qu'on
a identifié les sujets on était tout à
fait sans illusion sur les sujets qui
fâchent qu'il fallait en parler pour
tracer les lignes rouges
et puis les sujets sur lesquels on peut
faire des progrès et il ya deux sujets
fondamentaux
évidemment le président russe comme le
président américain sont tout à fait
conscients de la responsabilité commune
sur la stabilité stratégique du monde et
là dessus on créé un groupe de travail à
très haut niveau pour voir dans les
trois mois
quels progrès peuvent être faits dans
cette voie on fait la même chose sur les
cyber-attaques qui est très important et
là dessus
dans le fond le président poutine a bien
montré qu'il était prêt à examiner avec
les spécialistes américains ces
spécialistes et les spécialités
américain pour identifier les
responsabilités à chacune des
cyberattaques
plutôt que de s'envoyer des anathèmes à
la figure donc réussi réunion très
concrète et qui a permis de faire des
progrès et on retournera évidemment sur
ce discours on l'analysera plus en
profondeur on va donc je vous le disais
faire ce détour vers genève où l'on
retrouve olivier de caron flec olivier
vous vous avez suivi particulièrement le
discours dans de joe biden que faut-il
en retenir on entend des vladimir
poutine parler de relations
constructives joe biden lui parler de
tonalité positive on est sur la même
tonalité justement ah oui effectivement
stéphanie c'est la première chose qu'on
peut retenir ce soir a pressé ses deux
conférences de presse qui se sont
succédé un job hayden a parlé environ 45
minutes après son homologue russe
et bien c'est qu'ils en retiennent une
rencontre plutôt positive joe biden a
qualifié cet échange ces échanges de
très direct et il a précisé bien que
rien ne remplace le dialogue en tête à
tête il a aussi affirmé qu'il n'avait
rien contre la russie mais qu'il
privilégiait avant tout les intérêts
américains alors je vous propose
d'écouter plus généralement de jeu by
donne sur l'état d'esprit
sur l'état d'esprit avec lequel il a
vécu cette rencontre il était important
de se rencontrer en personne pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune erreur aucune fausse
représentation en ce qui concerne ce que
je souhaitais communiqué j'ai fait ce
que je voulais faire premièrement j'ai
identifié des domaines de travail
pratique pour le du pays pour favoriser
nos intérêts mutuels pour nous mêmes et
pour le monde deuxièmement communiquer
de manière directe directement que les
états unis réagiront à des actions qui
sont contre nos intérêts vitaux aussi
déshabiller et troisièmement énoncer
clairement quelles sont nos priorités
quels sont nos valeurs pour cool ils
l'entendent directement de ma bouche et
je dois vous dire que le la tonalité de
ses rencontres de plus de quatre heures
l'ambiance était bonne positive alors
une rencontre positive de façon générale
ça n'a pas empêché des deux hommes est
bien d'aborder les sujets qui fâchent
comme la sphère navalni a on le sait
elle a suscité énormément de tensions
ces dernières semaines ces derniers mois
alors pour le président américain
eh bien il est dit clairement que
vladimir poutine il a dit clairement à
vladimir poutine qu'ils s'opposaient au
traitement réservé à alexeï navalni l'a
dit également qu'il s'inquiétait de la
situation en biélorussie
parmi les gros dossiers qui ont été
évoqués on en parlait tout à l'heure
avec antoine claireaux c'est bien
évidemment celui de la cybersécurité
alors joe biden a déclaré avoir fait
part à son homologue bien que certaines
infrastructures ne devait jamais être
attaquée il a aussi précisé que les deux
pays avaient convenu de mandater des
experts afin d'encadrer un des experts
clés afin d'encadrer les pratiques par
l'on écouté j'ai parlé de cette idée que
certaines fractures stratégique ne
doivent jamais être attaqué point à la
ligne
une des manières cyberéthique autres je
lui ai donné une liste chiche de ma vie
je n'ai pas demain en moi mais il s
entité spécifique 16 entités définit
comme relevant de l'infrastructure sont
fondamentales des états unis les
systèmes de l'eau ce principe est
fondamentale et cela doit être étayé par
la pratique lépi responsables à prendre
des mesures contre les criminels qui
prennent des mesures de rang sans sur
leur propre territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus de
missionner des experts les deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compressions de ce
qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui leur origine dans l'un
ou l'autre de nos pays
et puis à joe biden a comme vladimir
poutine a insisté sur le fait que les
deux puissances avaient eu une
responsabilité par rapport à la
stabilité dans le monde par exemple sur
le dossier nucléaire iranien à joe biden
a dit à vladimir poutine qui a que
vladimir poutine avait convenu
s'investir pour que l'iran ne se dote
pas de l'armé nucléaire
et puis il y avait aussi cette question
des droits de l'homme
puisqu'on a vu le président américain
s'affiche et quelques jours avant la
rencontre et bien un peu comme le porte
parole des droits de l'homme c'est ce
qu'il disait notamment lors des
interviews accordés à des médias
américains
et bien sûr cette question il a répondu
également ce soir je vous propose de
l'écouter
j'ai dit au président poutine que mon
agenda n'est pas contre la russie ou
contre qui que ce soit d'autre
mon agenda et pour le peuple américain
pour lutter contre l' que vides
reconstruire notre économie rétablir nos
relations au tour du monde avec nos amis
et alliés et protéger le peuple
américain
cela constitue ma responsabilité en tant
que président je lui ai également dit
qu'aucun président des états unis ne
peut être honnête envers le peuple
américain s'il ne parle pas aux efforts
pour défendre nos valeurs démocratiques
se porter garant pour les valeurs
universelles de la liberté dont sont
dotés les hommes et les femmes selon
nous cela relève de l'adn de nos
dis donc les droits humains figurant
toujours sur la table je lui ai dit il
ne s'agit pas simplement de s'en prendre
à la russie lorsqu'il viole les droits
de l'homme non cela relève de notre état
de profond comment est-ce que moi
président des états unis
pour régis m'abstenir de parler contre
les violations des droits de l'homme je
le lui ai dit et pour conclure on peut
également retenir cette phrase du
président américain pour lui et bien
vladimir poutine ne cherche pas la
guerre froide voilà donc c'est avec ces
mots de joe biden que ce sommet
aujourd'hui cède ses tenues
c'était la première fois que les deux
hommes en tant que chef d'état se
rencontrait aujourd'hui ici à genève
stéphanie merci olivier de care flec et
on retrouve nos invités olivier ozon
claude blanchemaison hall garner olivier
d'ozon vladimir poutine ne cherche pas
une guerre froide avec les états unis
nous non plus a donc dit joe biden on
sait que les relations étaient au plus
bas juste avant cette rencontre entre la
russie et les etats unis est ce que
clairement ce soir une étape plutôt
positive a été franchi oui tout à fait
je pense que là si les rangs contacter
rappeuse et il n'était pas du tout
question de tension comme le prédisaient
les mais les médias il ya quelques jours
il ya quelques heures
je pense forcé clé que la réunion à
genève devait démarrer dans les
meilleurs auspices car by donne à faire
un cadeau qui est formidable il avait
supprimé par exemple les les sanctions à
l'encontre du du gazoduc nord stream à
tous qui est très important pour pour
relier pour relier à l'avenir le gaz le
gaz entre la russie et l'allemagne
donc ça veut dire que ce gazoduc
d'importance nous pourra pourra exister
dans dc suis moi ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
une très bonne nouvelle relève garner
même diagnostic
on peut dire que cette rencontre en tout
cas en apparence et plus tôt
réussite avec un climat d'apaisement
entre les deux hommes et dieu sait que
c'était plutôt mal parti même tout au
long de la journée les informations que
vous aviez nous avions n'étaient pas
vraiment positive sur sur la teneur des
discussions futures tout début on aurait
dit que baï canale adopté une posture
beaucoup plus sévère envers la russie
notamment concernant le canada dès que
l'administration d'alten a pris le
pouvoir il son projet à l'autre et et
new star c'était le début de la
coopération entre les deux puissances
et nous entrons maintenant dans une
deuxième étape qui plus la cybersécurité
donc c'est un processus par étapes vers
une coopération plus étroite et j'espère
que cela se développera au cours des
mois à venir
cependant encore beaucoup de chemin
avant d'atteindre une véritable
collaboration concernant par exemple
l'ukraine la biélorussie l'autre blanche
maison l'ukraine la biélorussie on sait
que c'était évidemment l'un des points
d'achoppement l'un des sujets qui
fâchent de cette réunion là aussi
de l'apaisement de l'apaisement enfin
dans la mesure où le président le
président américain a compris que il le
savait mais ça lui a été vraiment
préciser que pour le kremlin
la solution en ukraine ne peut venir que
de l'application des accords de minsk
tous les accords de mines c'est rien que
l accord des ministres en plus le
président poutine je crois à tracer une
ligne rouge très clair en disant il
n'est pas question pour la russie
d'accepter que l'ukraine rejoigne un
jour l'otan et ça c'est très important
je crois que c'était l'un des objets
aussi de cette réunion était que chacun
trace et les rouges
sachant que la transgression d'une de
ces lignes rouges entraînerait des
conséquences très sérieuses c'est à dire
et à dire un conflit et là cela cela a
été dit pour l'ukraine
le président by dell va recevoir ces 20
ski le président ukrainien dans quelques
semaines à washington
et donc qu'il connaît maintenant les
limites les limites du possible il faut
appliquer misc c'est difficile
politiquement pour le président et d'un
ski parce que effectivement au parlement
à la radars c'est très compliqué de
faire accepter l'autonomie de loin de
ces d'honnête et c'est encore plus
difficile de faire accepter des
élections aient lieu sans avoir recouvré
le contrôle de la frontière
mais peut-être que les solutions de
compromis sont possibles notamment en
faisant appel à l'ouest c'est eux pour
contrôler la frontière
olivier dose on sort ce dossier
ukrainien comme le dit claude branche
maison des compromis sont possibles vous
l'avez senti comme ça également en
écoutant les deux dirigeants ce soir oui
tout à fait tout à fait mais je pense
que cette réunion avait essayé tout
simplement une prise de contact et d'ici
quelques mois il ralliera discussions
seront plus technique
ce sera on rentre dans le dur c'est vrai
que je pense maison en tant qu ancien
ambassadeur ça vous le savez mieux que
quiconque
on s'est traditionnellement que ce genre
de sommet à bilatéraux pose des jalons
mais on
on constate dans les mois qui viennent
dans les semaines qui viennent si oui ou
non il ya de vraies avancées les choses
se font plus tard n'est ce pas c'est ce
qu'ont dit les deux présidents elle
prévient byden l'a dit nous ouvrirons
nos trois dans trois 3 mois
quels progrès ont été accomplis dans six
mois ce qui peut réussir et ainsi de
suite
et je crois que j'en reviens mon
qualificatif général c'était une réunion
très professionnelle ou les problèmes et
est identifié on ne parlait pas la
langue de bois où on disait les choses
sans s'invectiver et surtout en mettant
en place des procédures qui permettait
de faire des progrès en tout cas il ya
eu un acte concret tout de même c'est le
retour aux robes et ambassadeurs
respectifs des deux pays
sur place vous propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine à ce sujet concernant
le retour des ambassadeurs à leur place
habituelle de travail à moscou et à
washington
nous nous sommes convenus que cette
question est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
l'horreur abbas a de respectifs demain
ou après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain vont entamer des
consultations sur l'ensemble de notre
interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes j'ai l'impression que les deux
parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions à regarder ça c'est vraiment
un acte concret on le rappelle
des ambassadeurs parce que on rappelle
jamais assez que pour le moment enfin
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'y avait plus
d'ambassadeur en russe aux états unis et
américain à moscou
oui c'était une discussion au ridicule
les deux puissances vraiment échanger à
propos de vendre problème et un autre
progresser sans doute l'iran les états
unis et la russie sont d'accord pour
dire que l'iran ne devrait pas acquérir
d'armes nucléaires donc c'est une autre
étape positive mais également la corée
du nord où elle a réussi à une certaine
influence mais je pense que le problème
difficile sera l'élargissement de le
temps il ya eu des promesses pour à
l'intégration de l'otan à l'ukraine et à
la géorgie
mais le simple fait d'évoquer le
problème est très positif il faut
réfléchir au sens général à ce qui est
bon pour l'union européenne pour sa
sécurité ce qui est bien pour les états
unis et la russie et développer de
nouveaux arrangements pour la sécurité
dans ces régions et nous sommes déjà
pour le moment haletant la première
étape et nous avons encore beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir
olivier d'un an
le symbole de ce rapatriement si j'ose
dire des ambassadeurs ça dit beaucoup
sur la tonalité des relations futures
entre les deux pays
bien sûr c'est un préalable
je crois que je crois que quand on veut
discuter avec avec les pays c'est très
important d'avoir les représentants de
chacun ça c'était bien ce qu'on pourra
noter que c'est que c'est que les
ambassadeurs arrive dès demain donc ça
ça veut dire que c'était prévu dès le
départ que au niveau logistique des les
ambassadeurs vont pouvoir travailler
tout de suite vous marque une petite
pause est plutôt un détour plutôt qu'une
pause vers genève on va retrouver notre
envoyé spécial olivier de care en fait
qu'olivier de 45 qui se trouve avec guy
mettan journaliste également député au
grand conseil de genève n est ce pas
olivier s'appelle russie aussi dans une
guerre de milan oui effectivement
stéphanie je suis avec guy mettan
journalistes suisses vous le disiez
ancien directeur du club de suisse de la
presse parce que finalement et bien il y
avait aussi un troisième acteur
aujourd'hui c'est la suisse genève qui a
accueilli cette rencontre qui a mis un
dispositif de sécurité impressionnant
qui a d'ailleurs très bien fonctionné on
peut le dire ce soir
alors dis mais tant qu est ce que la
suisse finalement retiens de cette
rencontre ce soir
pour la suisse c'est évidemment une
satisfaction parce qu'il y avait un gros
stress pendant ces quinze derniers jours
pour justement préparer ce sommet paix
quand vous le savez les américains sont
extrêmement pointilleux en matière de
sécurité dont deux depuis 15 jours il ya
des centaines de gens des services
secrets services de différents services
de sécurité qui repère en ville qui
fouille dans tous les recoins justement
pour éviter des problèmes on peut les
comprendre
mais pour la suisse c'était un vrai défi
que de réussir organisé sommet pour voir
que c'est parfaitement raison
déroulé et qu'en plus certains résultats
semblent avoir été obtenues donc
effectivement pour notre pays c'est une
satisfaction mais ça vient couronner les
anciens sommet qu'avaient eu lieu par
exemple en 1985 entre reagan et
gorbatchev donc ça une suite pour nous
de l'organiser dans l'organisation de
ses sommets depuis 1815 à la suisse a le
statut de pays neutre ce soir comment
est ce que les journalistes notamment
ont pu observer cette rencontre qu'est
ce qu'il en ressort
la suisse est un pays neutre
malheureusement la presse us n'est pas
toujours aussi une autre que
personnellement je le souhaiterais parce
qu'elle est très biaisée souvent elle
est souvent tronqué en faveur de des
états unis de l'otan et des pays
européens est souvent assez rustre
frappe dans ses choix dans le choix de
ses experts mais aussi dans ses
éditoriaux mais je dois dire que la
couverture aujourd'hui a été très
correct ça à corriger un tout petit peu
les présentations de ces jours
précédents et puis j'ai observé
effectivement suivi les débats sur les
différentes chaînes pendant toute la
journée
est ce qu'on peut dire ce soir c'est
avantage poutine pendant la conférence
de presse le président russe a vraiment
dominé son sujet d'abord on voit qu'à
pas une table où beaucoup de sujets ont
été abordés au cours de cette rencontre
gemma désarmement pour ukraine
ça a été évoqué échange de prisonniers
rétablissement des ambassades donc on
voit que dans les discussions tout a pu
être abordé ce qui est un bon signe
elle présente à hesdin l'a d'ailleurs
confirmé mais on voit pendant la
conférence de presse dans les
commentaires que autour des mêmes
collègues américains étaient déçus au
fond de la prestation du président byden
est bon ça montre que le président russe
dire un petit peu près davantage au fond
l'administration américaine n'avait pas
voulu un d'une conférence de presse
commune ce soir à l'issue de la
rencontre ça a été une erreur finalement
à mon avis ça a été une erreur j'avais
cru effectivement bon de ne pas faire de
conférence de presse conjointe j'imagine
pour pâques donnait trop davantage à
monsieur poutine pendant cette
conférence est en réalité monsieur
poutine ayant parlé pendant 50 minutes
au préalable répondu avec une maestria
effectivement un contrôle de lui-même
très grand pas à toutes les questions
même délicate des herbes harassante qui
lui ont été posées près leur byden
d'ailleurs a réagi plus tard parce qu'il
a il a pris 20 minutes pour analyser de
ce qu'avait dit monsieur poutine pour
répondre ensuite vaud qui se pète est
dans la position de celui qui devait
répondre à son prédécesseur ce qui n'est
jamais bon dans la communication
au plus fort des techniques puisque ce
sont les américains qui ont choisi le
lieu de la conférence mais l'avait le
soleil à contre jour ce qui fait qu'il
était même un petit peu desservi par par
le choix que les américains eux-mêmes
fait pour cette le choix du lieu qu'ils
avaient eux-mêmes pour cette conférence
et personnellement j'en suis très
heureux parce que je disais le
déferlement de la propagande anti russe
dans les médias occidentaux étaient si
forts avant ce sommet que je pense que
grâce au président poutine on a pu
rétablir un tout petit peu mieux
des choses pour mieux faire comprendre
au fond les préoccupations de la russie
au reste du monde parce que finalement
elles ont à peine à être exprimées à
peine en tout cas exprimé dans les
médias
et puis des décisions concrètes entre
les deux pays puisque les ambassadeurs
vont pouvoir retourner dans les
capitales des deux puissances est
également le président suisse a déclaré
que vladimir poutine lors d'une réunion
avec lui avait déclaré la nécessité de
coopérer au développement donc il y a eu
finalement aussi pour la suisse des
déclarations concrète ce soir notre
président et notre ministère des
affaires étrangères ont rencontré
monsieur poutine
monsieur lavera ils ont surtout évoqué
des questions économiques
le soutien aux entreprises russes qui
aux entreprises pendant qu'ils
investissent ans en russie vous savez
qu'à genève
c'est un centre extrêmement important
pour le commerce pour reading des
matières premières l'essentiel du
pétrole et du gaz russe se négocie ici
agenais donc c'est une place importante
aussi pour la russie et la suisse figure
au top ce thème dans le classement des
dix premiers investisseurs étrangers en
russie d'aucun les liens économiques
sont effectivement importante nos deux
pays
merci beaucoup de nous avoir accompagnés
ce soir ici à genève je le rappelle vous
êtes journaliste suisse ancien directeur
du club suisse de la presse notamment
voilà stéphanie la suisse 1 qui a réussi
son pari finalement d'accueillir au
mieux ce sommet entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui
merci à olivier vous parler du fait
qu'il n'y avait pas de conférence
commune entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden et pour cause peut-être pour
éviter un de psychodrame dans certains
16 juillet 2018 ou un certain vladimir
poutine toujours le même et donald trump
se rencontrer pour la toute première
fois on pouvait alors entrevoir une
normalisation des relations bilatérales
mais cette rencontre a provoqué un tollé
aux etats unis puisque donald trump
avait fustigé un a été fait avait été
fustigée pour avoir blanchi 1 moscou
détriment des services secrets
américains emilie gogh h pour le
rappelle la volonté d'un rapprochement
russo américain aura marqué ce sommet
d'helsinki
alors que nombre d'observateurs
s'attendaient à une rencontre sous haute
tension
ces pourparlers avait été décrit comme
très réussi et utile par vladimir
poutine
les pourparlers avec le président
américain donald trump se sont déroulées
dans une atmosphère ouverte et
professionnels je les considère comme
très réussie utile nous avons examiné
l'état actuel et la perspective des
relations russo américaines ainsi que
les questions clé de l'agenda
international
les désaccords entre nos deux pays sont
bien connus et le président étienne et
moi en avons longuement discuté
aujourd'hui
mais si nous voulons résoudre les
nombreux problèmes auxquels notre monde
est confronté
nous devons trouver des moyens de
coopérer afin de satisfaire nos intérêts
communs
parmi les sujets abordés la situation en
syrie
la crimée le nucléaire mais aussi les
accusations d'ingérence de la russie
dans l'élection présidentielle
américaine de novembre 2016 qui avait vu
la victoire de donald trump et sur ce
point
pendant la conférence de presse commune
donald trump avait fait une déclaration
ce site en un tollé au sein de la classe
politique américaine le président
poutine m'a dit que ce n'est pas à la
russie
je vais vous dire je ne vois aucune
raison pour laquelle ce serait la russie
une remise en cause des enquêtes des
services de renseignement américains
critiqué dans le camp démocrate comme
dans celui du président le parti
républicain dans toute l'histoire de
notre pays
les américains n'avaient jamais vu un
président des états unis soutenir un
adversaire de l'amérique comme donald
trump vient de soutenir le président
poutine
il n'ya pas moralement d'équivalence
entre les états unis et la russie qui
demeurent hostiles à nos idéaux et à nos
valeurs fondamentales
les etats unis doivent s'attacher à
demander des comptes à la russie et à
mettre fin des attaques ignobles contre
la démocratie
donald trump avait fini par revenir sur
ses propos
il avait aussi accusé ses détracteurs
d'être dérangés par sa bonne entente
avec vladimir poutine
leur sommet à d'ailleurs été marqué par
cette image
à l'issue de cette conférence de presse
commune vadimir poutine avait offert un
ballon de football à donald trump et
déclaré que la balle était dans son camp
et on retrouvera le gartner ans
professeur de politique internationale à
l'université américaine de paris
évidemment cette séquence on s'en
souvient tous on va j'imagine avoir
droit à une toute autre tonalité dans la
relation personnelle en tout cas entre
ces deux hommes de la dea me recruter
mais joe biden pourtant on a senti
arrêtez moi si je me trompe une forme
quand même de respect ce soir entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine plutôt
inattendue
à adopter la maison roche ont considéré
que trump été gentil avec la russie avec
poutine qui a une image très négative
les états unis étaient considérés comme
trop et de ce fait n'a pas pu développer
des politiques avec la russie car elle
ne considérait pas comme assez sévères
joe biden arrivent en disant c'est un
adversaire qui en vaut la peine donc il
respecte son rival et à travers ce
respect on peut coopérer davantage à
battre davantage de problèmes de travail
et à barack obama a eu le même problème
car on l'a entendue lors d'une
conversation alors qu' il n'était pas
censé s'exprimer publiquement
et bien des journalistes ont capté ces
propos et qui disant qu'il voulait
travailler derrière le système si on
semble trop laxiste avec la russie on
n'arrive pas à ses fins eh bien on va
voir justement ce qu'en pensent les
américains comment ont-ils vécu en sept
rencontres entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden on va retrouver en direct à
washington notre reporter thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas alors comment les
américains réagissent t-il ce soir ce
matin à la mi-journée même pour vous
beaucoup de réactions d'abord sur la
conférence de presse de joe biden
puisqu'en fait à la toute fin de cette
conférence de presse il ya eu une passe
d'armes entre le président américain et
une journaliste de cnn avec
vraisemblablement une question qui a
plutôt des plus au locataire de la
maison blanche qui a répondu de manière
assez sèche à la journaliste la
polémique et être en train d'enfler si
bien que juste avant de prendre l'avion
air force one
joe biden a pris le soin d'aller voir
les journalistes qui étaient présents
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport pour leur
préciser qu'il souhaitait présenter ses
excuses à cette journaliste qu'il
n'aurait pas dû se comporter comme ça
voilà donc pour la petite anecdote à la
suite de cette conférence de presse de
joe biden une conférence de presse où on
l'a vu est question avait été soumise au
préalable ces jo bayal lui même qui
appelait les les reporter à poser leurs
questions aux nôtres on notera aussi
qu'il n'y avait pas de journalistes
russes par exemple qui étaient présents
à cette conférence de presse a en tout
cas sur la teneur des discussions et des
différentes annonces qui ont été faites
cet après midi finalement ça pas
vraiment convaincu ceux qui étaient
contre ce sommet le sont toujours on a
notamment des éleveurs et des
représentants républicains qui
critiquent la position de joe biden qui
les accuse de ne pas avoir fait preuve
d'assez de fermeté face à vladimir
poutine et puis l inverse démocrates eux
récupèrent la rhétorique de joe biden en
mettant en avant
justement les dossiers sensibles qu'il a
pu aborder avec le président russe
on a eu aussi le droit toute la journée
à l'analyse des images de la gestuelle
par les médias américains notamment cnn
qui analysait donc tout les faits et
gestes des deux présidents pendant leurs
différentes rencontres avec parfois des
choses qui ne fait pas très honnête
parce qu'on avait des captures d'écran
notamment qui étaient postés sur les
réseaux sociaux de la part de
journalistes de cnn
par exemple pour expliquer que vladimir
poutine avait détourné le regard au
moment de la poignée de mains avec joe
biden ou encore pour dire que
l'atmosphère était lourde dans la salle
où on a pu voir les deux présidents la
salle qui avait été ouverte à la presse
alors qu'en réalité lorsqu'on voyait
l'intégralité des images on s'apercevait
que l'ambiance était bien différente à
celle qui était présentée par donc les
médias notamment les journalistes de cnn
plus généralement les médias ici aux
etats unis son vous savez assez clément
avec joe biden sur notre sur la plupart
de sa politique et notamment sur sa
politique internationale et je propose
de regarder ce
ce récupérer récapitulatif pardon des
médias juste avant le sommet qui avait
organisé en 2018 entre donald trump et
vladimir poutine à helsinki et le sommet
qui a eu lieu cet après midi vous allez
voir la rhétorique est complètement
différente voire même opposé le
président john essaie d'être non
seulement la voix la plus forte contre
l'autoritarisme dans le monde mais
également le meilleur exemple de la
raison pour laquelle le modèle
autoritariste est défaillante
il ne s'agit pas de conclure des accords
mais de fixer les limites avec la russie
selon mbaye donné ses conseillers
l'objectif est de regarder poutine droit
dans les yeux vous venez d'assister à ce
qui est sans doute la pire prestation
d'un président des états unis lors d'un
sommet face un dirigeant russe
ce que je n'ai jamais vu une conférence
de presse hors du commun
je pense que les américains n'ont encore
jamais vu de conférence de presse de la
sorte entre un président américain et un
dirigeant russe décrit par tous nos
alliés comme un adversaire est un
adversaire dangereux
vous le voyez le traitement médiatique
et très différents entre joe biden et
donald trump est d'ailleurs les équipes
de la maison blanche ont vraiment pris
le soin de ne pas organiser de
conférence de presse conjointe entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine justement pour
éviter les critiques des médias à
l'époque contre l'ancien président des
états unis en direct de washington et
nous sommes toujours sur ce plateau avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales notamment club blanche
maison on imagine que pour le président
russe a tout de même été une forme de
soulagement d'entendre aux jo maiden
traiter la russie de voler deux
superpuissances de grande puissance
alors que l'on se souvient que le
prédécesseur avant au trump
obama lui par les deux puissances
régionales ce que ce qui n'était pas au
bout du président du sein tout à fait et
joe biden a bien reconnu que les deux
pays avaient la co responsabilité de la
stabilité stratégique mondial qui leur
appartenait parce que c'est eux qui
avaient le plus de j'aime venu
r le plus de fusée balistique et les
vins sont les armes les plus modernes et
bien c'était eux qui leur venaient
d'être responsables de la stabilité de
la stabilité stratégique mondial en
faisant cela d'ailleurs ils en font
c'est un petit peu un coin entre la
russie et la chine
parce que la chine est le rival fera
tegick systémique de deux états unis ce
qui n'est pas le cas de la russie et la
russie est un partenaire pour rétablir
la stabilité stratégique dans le monde
et je crois que c'était aussi un des
objets de cette rencontre c'est on ne
sait pas ce qui s'est dit sur la chine
entre les deux présidents peut-être rien
du tout d'ailleurs
mais le président poutine est tout à
fait conscient des limites de ce
rapprochement avec la chine est tout à
fait conscient du fait qu'il a aussi
intérêt à parler aux états unis à parler
à l'europe de façon à maintenir un
équilibre alors que l'on voit air force
one en deuxième plan de boeing 747 400
du président américain qui va s'envoler
dans quelques instants du tarmac de
genève afin donc de cette première ce
premier voyage en europe 1 ce premier
jet set pour joe biden cette première
rencontre bilatérale avec vladimir
poutine
le gartner on parlait de des relations
entre le président russe et les
différents présidents américains parce
qu'il y en a eu plusieurs et
effectivement la tenue de ce sommet
illustre en elle-même le fait que la
russie soit une puissance importante aux
yeux des etats-unis n'est ce pas
américaine à la fin de la guerre froide
nous nous croyons devenu le seul pôle de
puissance du monde comme pouvions
intervenir en irak en afghanistan et
cetera les etats unis ont commencé à
repenser leurs relations avec le reste
du monde à reconnaître que la russie
joue un rôle important que les états
unis et la russie doivent résoudre des
conflits en commun j'ai parlé de l'iran
de la corée du nord et bien sûr le gros
problème sera l'ukraine et la crimée
mais c'est typiquement un nouveau pas en
avant qui peut mener vers davantage de
collaboration afin de forger un nouveau
sens de sécurité et de paix dans le
monde
olivier doses ont essayé ce consultant
en relations internationales vous êtes
également toujours avec nous pour nous
décrypter en scène différentes
conférences de presse et cette rencontre
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden joe
biden qui disait tout à l'heure
voilà qui contient ce sentiment qu'avait
en tout cas supposé un cave et vladimir
poutine que les états unis cherchaient à
rabaisser parfois la russie est ce qu'il
y a de cela
sincèrement dans les faits oui oui alors
moi genre moi j'ai regardé le discours
et la méthodologie qui concerne l otan
et il ya qu'il ya quelques mois il ya
quelques mois la russie était considéré
comme un grand à un cas un grand satan
maintenant maintenant je pense que c'est
plus le cas et que l'otan l'otan va
pouvoir penser à une stratégie qui va
qui va lutter contre la contre la chine
et c'est vrai que l'ambassadeur claude
blanchemaison avait raison le sujet de
le sujet important c'est bien la chine
or on sait pas ce qui a été dit si evans
a été abordé de c'est vrai que c'est un
cétacé d'un sujet qui va tram et qui va
qui va structurer la géopolitique
actuelle et future
c'est vrai que dans une maison que la
chine
on en a pas parlé officiellement ce soir
ni dans les bouches de joe madden ni de
vladimir poutine peut-être que pékin a
été sur toutes les lèvres de cet or
rencontres en coulisse en tout cas les
ied jean ping ont du bourdonné en effet
car on en a sans doute pas parler
ouvertement
mais elle était elle était implicitement
là puisque c'est en effet le vrai sujet
et c'est le sujet d'ailleurs sur lequel
on quitterait beaucoup d'aujourd'hui
anglo saxons à la suite du sommet de
l'otan comme ça vient d'être cas
peut-être dit à l'instant la chine rend
le gardeur la nouvelle obsession enfin
la nouvelle pas vraiment meilleur
l'obsession en tout cas américaine
c'est bien ça certainement le vrai
concurrent le vrai rival des états unis
c'est tout à fait correct
la chine est en des termes militaires
est évoqué comme rival militaire
c'est-à-dire sont légales et les
craintes d'une alliance entre la chine
et la russie est l'un des moteurs de ce
rapprochement
l'objectif est non pas d'essayer ou
d'écarter la russie et la chine ou
plutôt de retourner la chine contre la
russie et vice versa mais en tout cas de
les écarter pour éviter qu'elles forment
une alliance
vous restez avec nous tous les trois
messieurs pour ce décryptage on va faire
un détour vers genève on va retrouver
notre envoyé spécial en toile claireaux
un 20h43 en direct sur arte france
bonsoir re bonsoir antoine vous avez
vous eu tout particulièrement suivi
l'allocution de vladimir poutine s'était
en toute fin d'après midi il a eu donc
la primeur du décryptage de cette
rencontre bilatérale fait quoi
oui tout à fait j'étais dans la salle où
cette conférence de presse s'est
déroulée même si l'entrevue entre les
deux présidents a duré un tout petit peu
moins de temps que prévu
eh bien ils ont eu le temps malgré tout
d'abord des de très nombreuses
thématiques on pense en particulier à
l'ukraine et cette ligne rouge que
constitue pour le kremlin
sa possible adhésion à l'otan est aussi
le conflit dans l'est du pays et pour
vladimir poutine il n'existe qu'une
seule solution pour ce conflit c'est
bien la mise en oeuvre totale et
complète des accords de minsk il a
d'ailleurs fait savoir que le président
américain partager son avis il ya aussi
deux dossiers longuement évoquée par les
deux hommes c'est bien la cie percer la
cyber sécurité et la stabilité
stratégique de dossiers sur lesquels les
deux hommes ont convenu d'une
coopération dit qu'une coopération était
possible et même au delà que des
consultations au plus haut niveau allait
avoir lieu sur ces deux thématiques il
est aussi bien entendu la sphère navali
des questions qui ont été posées
particulièrement par les médias les
médias britanniques et américains au
moins trois questions durant sa
conférence de presse russe alexeï
navalni pour sujet la réponse de
lanières poutine n'a pas varié pour le
président russe
il a dénoncé tout simplement le fait que
son organisation l'organisation d'
alexeï navalni appel à des
manifestations interdites et qui plus
est des mineurs ce qui est tout à fait
illégal au niveau de la constitution
russe
il y a également eu des d'autres sujets
bien entendu d'évoquer comme l'arctique
et les droits de l'homme pour n'en citer
que quelques-uns
si antoine clairon direct de jeunes
avaient justement sur ces droits de
l'engagement propose d'écouter avant
d'en parler avec vous que l'odeur
blanchemaison vladimir poutine qui tacle
un petit peu le président américain sur
cette question des droits de l'homme
écoutez concernant nos engagements vis à
vis de l'ukraine
nous avons un seul engagement contribuer
à la réalisation des accords de mise
comme si que la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire on va entamer cette
voie sans aucun doute je porte votre
attention sur le fait que novembre
dernier la délégation ukrainienne nous a
adressé ses estimations sur st leur
vision des accords de minsk
il parle de l'intégration politique du
dans basse dans le système politique
ukrainien et dans la constitution
ukrainienne a donc il faut apporter des
amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne en ski au sein des droits de
l'homme et je continue à travailler
il ya des choses qui ne respectent ni
les lois américaines ni les principes
des droits de l'homme il y avait un
hameau il ya les prisons de la cia ou
les tortures ont été appliquées et ça
c'est quoi c'est le sait les droits de
l'homme peut-être je pense que non est
ce que quelqu'un ici dans la salle sera
est prêt à dire que c'est la défense des
droits de l'homme ces prisons donc c'est
la politique
voilà donc venir continuent sur cette
question des droits de l'homme alors que
le boeuf maisons sont des petits tacles
réciproque parce que la conférence de
presse suivant de joe biden joe biden
voilà à la cité des comparaisons
ridicule de la part de venir poutine sur
les droits de l'homme on se renvoie un
petit peu là
là bas c'est de bonne guerre oui cette
manière et vladimir poutine a contre
attaqué en effet vladimir poutine a
contre attaqué en parlant de guantanamo
des prisons de la cia y est et puis des
gens qui aussi se faisait tuer dans les
écoles dans les églises dans les rues de
certains de certaines villes les états
unis donc il a contre attaqué mais en
faisant cela
d'une certaine manière il a dit les
droits de l'homme hockey parlons-en les
torts sont bien partagées il ya des
problèmes chez vous il ya des problèmes
chez nous par le gartner
effectivement l'objet en cette question
des droits de l'homme qui était
forcément attendu qui a donné lieu voilà
des petits tacles à on sent qu'on ne va
pas nécessairement s'accorder sur cette
question a fait que ce taux ressort du
broker qui regarde par exemple les
conditions dans l'univers carcéral
aux états unis il y a trop de gens en
prison il ya ces mêmes problèmes en
russie en chine voudrait en fait que les
acteurs se rassemblent et imaginer
ensemble comment améliorer les lois
comment mieux traiter les gens une bonne
gouvernance devrait être clé alors on
pourrait commencer à gérer ce sujet
majeur
olivier d'ozon dans la lignée des droits
de l'homme il ya eu évidemment les
leçons de morale sur alexeï navalni le
dossier n'a pas manqué d'être abordée
avec une mise en garde de joe biden et
une défense
de vladimir poutine oui cette question
cette question d'importance mais je
pense qu'elles n'intéressent plus en
plus les occidentaux que le que les
russes et c'est pas c'est pas la
question des droits de l'homme qu'on
retiendra c'est pas c'est pas dans le
cadre de cette compte de cette
conférence avec byron et baï d'année et
poutine jacques est la question des
droits de l'homme
c'est pas c'est pas là ce n'est pas le
plus important c'est pas le même temps
c'est la hausse des rôles de la chine
qui a qui mériterait d'être développés
oui mais pourtant joe biden
s'est montré assez voilà entre
guillemets menaçant à la question de
savoir s'il arrivait quelque chose
alexeï navalni en prison voilà ce serait
lourd à payer comme conséquence pour
pour la russie donc aux yeux
manifestement du président américain
cette question est d'importance mais je
crois que je crois que poutine a bien
répondu sur la question et que poutine
fera en sorte que la vanille ne ne meurt
pas en prison autre sujet qui fâche la
cyber sécurité
les deux hommes ont évidemment aborder
ce dossier je me propose de les écouter
tous deux j'ai parlé de cette idée que
certains a fracturé stratégique ne
doivent jamais être attaqué point à la
ligne
une des manières cyberéthique ou autre
je lui donnais une liste si je m'abuse
je n'ai pas demain en moi mais il ya 16
entités spécifiques 16 entités définit
comme relevant de l'infrastructure
fondamentale des états unis les six
thèmes de l'eau ce principe est
fondamentale et cela doit être étayé par
la pratique lépi responsables à prendre
des mesures contre les criminels qui
prennent des mesures de rang sans sur
leur propre territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus de
missionner des experts des deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compréhension de
ce qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui origine dans l'un ou
l'autre de nos pays''
concernant la cybersécurité nous avons
convenu d'entamer des consultations à ce
sujet c'est selon moi extrêmement
important maintenant qu'ils devraient
prendre quelle obligation
je veux vous informer de choses qui sont
généralement connus mais pas par le
grand public
de source américaine j'ai juste peur de
me tromper dans le nom de l'organisation
mais peskov vous le transmettra plus
tard
il ressort de source américaine que le
plus grand nombre de cyber attaques dans
le monde sont effectués à partir du
cyberespace américain en deuxième place
se trouve le canada puis il y a deux
pays d'amérique latine et enfin la
grande bretagne la russie ne fait pas
partie de cette liste de pays à partir
desquels le plus grand nombre de cyber
attaques de toutes sortes sont effectués
comme vous pouvez le constater c'est la
première chose deuxièmement en 2020 nous
avons reçu dix demandes des etats-unis
concernant des cyber attaques visant des
infrastructures américaines comme le
disent nos collègues depuis le
cyberespace russe et il y a deux
demandes de ce genre cette année à
toutes ses demandes
l'année dernière et cette année nos
collègues ont reçu des réponses
exhaustives à son tour la russie a
envoyé 45 demandes de ce type à
l'organisation concernés aux états unis
l'année dernière et au premier semestre
de cette année 35
nous n'avons reçu pour l'instant aucune
réponse maison on affiche sa fermeté de
part et d'autre et on se renvoie la
balle
cyber attaque c'est bien créés diminue
crédibilité criminalité il y en a de
plus en plus de par le monde et je crois
que dubaï dana a tracé une ligne rouge
là encore en faisant savoir que si
certains centres stratégiques civil ou
militaire faisait l'objet d'une attaque
cyber il y aurait des mesures de
rétorsion avec la technologie la plus
moderne dans les états unis peuvent
disposer de certains pays le font déjà
d'ailleurs et je crois que la france le
fait quand ça lui arrive deuxièmement
cybercriminels criminalité à ce moment
là bien entendu lorsqu'il ya des groupes
privés qui demandent des rançons en
faisant des ataxies vert en bloquant un
système
informatique évidemment il serait tout à
fait logique que les pays se mettent
ensemble pour traquer les cyber
criminels et peut-être pour en effet les
empêcher de nuire et les arrêter et là
dessus je crois que c'est l'objet de
troisième fois c'est la proposition qui
a été faite
un groupe de travail pour précisément
voir dans quelle mesure on pourrait
analyser les responsabilités et mettre
en place un dispositif qui permettrait
de traquer les cyber criminels
merci claude blanche saison et merci de
nous avoir surtout accompagné pour cette
heure de décryptage à passer de
conférence de presse merci également à
olivier doses ont essayé ce consultant
en relations internationales et merci
également un rôle garner professeur de
politique internationale à l'université
américaine de paris on va marquer une
courte pause on se retrouve à 21h
émission spéciale évidemment consacré
cette première rencontre inédite entre
joe biden et vladimir poutine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans les
relations entre la russie aujourd'hui
venir travailler en russie
nouer des partenariats pose des
problèmes dans la mesure où vous pouvez
être confronté à un partenaire qui est
sous sanction notamment américaines le
commerce ne se développe pas ah non ils
ont fait entre la france je pensais la
russie maintenant elle joue très frustré
dire que la russie produits russes mais
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il pourrait
s'affranchir de la surpuissance des gaza
par exemple s'affranchisse de la
technologie européenne pour pour tous se
développer des entreprises françaises
qui ont un futur en russie ce sont
celles qui peuvent leur apporter à
savoir faire après la question est ça va
parce qu'elles resteront
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernières poches l'emporter en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très estimé les français ne
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge ans et demi
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il shoote ont encore à protéger
totalement les femmes
on dit souvent femme posée en parler
briser le silence
nous savons que seulement 18 19 % des
femmes révèle les violences qu'elles
subissent donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80%
de femmes qui ne révèle pas les
violences qu'elles subissent aux forces
de sécurité dont celle qui rêvait il
faut vraiment les croix et les protéger
souvent on met toute la responsabilité
sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h heure de paris soyez les bienvenus
en direct sur rt france bienvenue pour
cette deuxième heures d'émissions
consacrées entièrement ce soir au sommet
de genève entre eux joe boyd années
vladimir poutine dispositif exceptionnel
avec nos envoyés spéciaux olivier de
kerran flec à genève et antoine
claireaux sur place également nos
invités pour le décryptage de ce tête à
tête inédit et la rencontre avec joe
biden a donc été constructive il n'y
avait aucune animosité voilà comment
vladimir poutine a résumé cet entretien
inédit avec son homologue américain même
son cloche du côté de joe biden qui
évoque une tonalité je suis positive
avant cette rencontre les relations
étaient pourtant au plus bas entre
washington et moscou après 3h30
d'entrevues les deux dirigeants ont
obtenu séparément une conférence de
presse ce soir et on va prendre tout de
suite la direction jeu genève où l'on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial olivier de
kerran flec
olivier bonsoir vous avez
particulièrement vous suivi la
conférence de presse de joe biden qui
est passé si j'ose dire
après vladimir poutine et la tonalité du
sommet pour lui pour le président
américain était positive
oui tout à fait stéphanie alors comme
vous le disiez 1
il est intervenue 45 minutes après son
homologue russe vladimir poutine
et pourquoi bien parce que
l'administration weiden avait choisi de
ne pas organiser une conférence de
presse commune donc pas de prise de
parole
en même temps entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine alors c'est le même son
de cloche un que du côté russe du côté
américain on est satisfaits 1 2 de cette
rencontre joe biden a qualifié cette
rencontre de très direct il a précisé
qu'il n'ya rien qui ne puisse remplacer
le dialogue en tête à tête
je vous propose de l'écouter justement
sur l'état d'esprit de ce sommet
aujourd'hui à genève
il était important de se rencontrer en
personne pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
erreur aucune fausse représentation en
ce qui concerne ce que je souhaitais
communiqué j'ai fait ce que je voulais
faire premièrement j'ai identifié des
domaines de travail pratique pour le du
pays pour favoriser nos intérêts mutuels
pour nous mêmes et pour le monde
deuxièmement communiquer de manière
directe directement que les états unis
réagiront à des actions qui sont contre
nos intérêts vitaux aussi deux alliés et
troisièmement énoncer clairement quelles
sont nos priorités quels sont nos
valeurs pour qu'il entende directement
de ma bouche et je dois vous dire que le
la tonalité de ses rencontres de plus de
quatre heures
l'ambiance était bonne positive
à
voilà un petit problème de liaison ont
manifestement avec olivier de claire
enflait qui nous décrivent et décrypté
plus tôt cette conférence de presse du
président américain joe biden avec nous
pourrons parler également nos invités
bruno bref ce qui met de conférences à
l'institut national des langues et
civilisations orientales spécialiste de
l'europe médiane bonsoir à vous bruno
presse qui merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés yves pozzo di borgo président de
l'institut lecanu et ancien sénateur udi
de paris bonsoir à vous également et
enfin théo lobry journaliste indépendant
spécialiste des états unis bonsoir à
tous les trois merci d'être avec nous
ils photo di borgo
comment vous avez ressenti ces deux
rencontres cette rencontre bilatérale
inédite en l'avenir foot il nous a dit
d'un côté une rencontre positive joe
biden tonalité positive est également
vous l'avez ressenti vous aussi ah bon
je trouve que ce qui s'est passé est
quelque chose de très important et je
trouve que ça a été une journée très
positifs pour l'europe et pour la russie
pour l'amérique
alors évidemment juste tendance un peu à
faire du bourg en disant ça va obliger
tous nos amis de l'union européenne à
qui faisaient du zèle antirusse un peu à
corriger leurs tirs parce qu'il était
toujours suivre les américains c'est
juste un peu d'humour mais je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de le dire par contre je
crois qu'il faut derrière cette séquence
biden en europe c'est-à-dire d'abord le
g7 ensuite l'otan ensuite l'union
européenne et en suisse était rencontre
biden
poutine je crois qu'il faut vraiment ne
pas être naïf et voir qui a une grande
inquiétude des américains face à la
chine
la vieille thèse brénaz qui vous savez
qu'ils considèrent que le prochain
conflit mondial à face était le
conseiller de carter qui considère que
le prochain leveaux le grand débat entre
les deux puissances mondiales sera le
débat entre la chine et les états unis
mais je crois que les états unis avec
cette séquence mitaine sans rentrer dans
ce débat
voilà c'est à dire qu'ils ont vraiment
ils ont d'abord compris qu'il fallait
entraîné les européens notamment d'un
cas de l'otan sert l'otan c'est
atlantiste et là les heureuses et des
américains biden veut sortir le temps du
cac d'atlantis deuxièmement ils valent
également s'ils voulaient ils sont des
comptes que la avec les sanctions la
politique un peu stupide qui avait été
menée de la part des états unis à
l'égard des européens aussi à l'égard
des de la russie que la russie allait
dans les bras de la chine
et on a bien vu que cette rencontre
aujourd'hui est un petit peu pour
directement repas continuer à faire
autant de bêtises et je crois que la
chose importante de cette séquence qui
n'est pas uniquement leur encontre
huitaine poutine cette séquence du
voyage de bidet nos eaux en europe c'est
ça c'est à dire que se profilent cette
grande bataille au jeu passera j'espère
sera pas une guerre mais cette grande
bataille du savoir qui sera qui aura le
contrôle mondial du monde qui sera la
puissance globale il faut savoir que les
chinois attendent ils considèrent qu'on
dit en 2045 qui sera la grande puissance
globale et que les états unis sont la
grande puissance globale ils se rendent
compte qu'ils sont concurrencés par la
chine
je rajoute aurait une chose aussi c'est
qu'il ya derrière tout ça problème
démographique vous avez d'un côté les
occidentaux
un milliard de personnes se dire entre
les états unis l'europe et la russie et
de l'autre vous avez la chine avec le
monde entier que parce que sept
milliards de personnes
je dis ça parce que j'étais moi
parlementaire à l'assemblée
parlementaire 2 mondial est ma dernière
réunion comme parlementaire c'était à
dacca au bangladesh
c'était en 2002 en 2017 et j'ai bien vu
cette coupure d'un côté des occidentaux
dans laquelle il ya les américains les
européens et puis les russes mais était
hésitant et qui jouait plutôt avec
l'asie centrale
d'autre côté le reste du monde qui ne
supportent plus les occidentaux je crois
que derrière tout ça cette séquence
biden en europe veux vous montrer que le
prochain combat j'espère sera pas une
guerre ça sera des combats économique
sur des combats de débats ce sera des
combats également de deux contrôles de
la delà des opinions publiques
ça sera la chine contre les états unis
qui sera la grande puissance mondiale
on va revenir avec vous bruno bref ce
qui est théo lobry dans quelques
instants mais on va laisser olivier de
kerran flec qu'on a récupéré 1,2 de
genève la liaison a été rétablie à
nouveau poursuivre son décryptage faim
sont résumées en tout cas de cette
conférence de presse de joe biden tout à
l'heure olivier oui effectivement
stéphanie alors on parlait un de l'état
d'esprit de cette rencontre joe biden la
saluer il a qualifié de très direct les
échanges qu'il a eus avec son homologue
russe alors il ya eu beaucoup de
dossiers qui ont été abordés et
notamment un dossier qui fâche c'est l
affaire navalni qui a suscité pas mal de
tensions ces dernières semaines entre
les deux puissances est bien le
président américain a dit clairement à
vladimir poutine qu'ils s'opposaient au
traitement réservé à alexeï navalni
autre sujet qui a largement été évoquée
aujourd'hui lors de ce sommet bien c'est
la cybersécurité de au bail donne a
déclaré avoir fait part à son homologue
russe que certaines infrastructures ne
devait jamais être attaqué il a aussi
précisé que les deux pays avaient
convenu et vient de mandater des experts
pour encadrer ces pratiques écoutez j'ai
parlé de cette idée que certains a
fracturé stratégique ne doivent jamais
être attaqué point à la ligne
de manière cyberéthique ou autre je lui
donnais une liste si je m'abuse je n'ai
pas demain en moi mais il ya 16 entités
spécifiques 16 entités définit comme
relevant de l'infrastructure
fondamentale des états unis les six
thèmes de l'eau ce principe est
fondamentale et cela doit être étayé par
la pratique les pays responsables à
prendre des mesures contre les criminels
qui prennent des mesures de rançons sur
leur propre territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus de
missionner des experts des deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compressions de ce
qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui origine dans l'un ou
l'autre de nos pays
alors on vous parlait effectivement de
la sphère navalni un dossier qui fâche
il il y en a un autre c'est la question
des ingérences dans les dernières
élections présidentielles et bien il
s'est exprimé à ce propos le président
américain il a déclaré que vladimir
poutine savait qu'il prendrait des
mesures pour que ces agissements ne se
poursuive pas comment serions nous perçu
si les états unis pratiquer ce type
d'ingérence s'est interrogé un joe biden
on le rappelle un et il n'y a toujours
aucune preuve de ces ingérences de la
russie lors des élections
présidentielles aux états unis et puis
joe biden et bien s'est exprimé sur la
question des droits de l'homme parce
qu'effectivement avant cette réunion et
bien il s'est affiché un peu comme le
porte parole des droits de l'homme il
avait exprimé à plusieurs reprises dans
les médias avant de venir ici à genève
est bien la question il a évoqué
également lors de cette conférence de
presse écoutez j'ai dit au président
poutine que mon agenda n'est pas contre
la russie ou contre qui que ce soit
d'autre
mon agenda et pour le peuple américain
pour lutter contre la queue vide
reconstruire notre économie
rétablir nos relations au tour du monde
avec nos amis et alliés et protéger le
peuple américain
cela constitue ma responsabilité en tant
que président je lui ai également dit
qu'aucun président des états unis ne
peut être honnête envers le peuple
américain s'il ne parle pas aux efforts
pour défendre nos valeurs démocratiques
se porter garant pour les valeurs
universelles de la liberté dont sont
dotés les hommes et les femmes selon
nous cela relève de l'adn de notre pays
donc les droits humains figurant
toujours sur la table je lui ai dit il
ne s'agit pas simplement de s'en prendre
à la russie lorsqu'il viole les droits
de l'homme non cela relève de notre état
de profond comment est-ce que moi
président des états unis pour agir
m'abstenir de parler contre les
violations des droits de l'homme je le
lui ai dit voilà joe biden qui a défendu
cette position à des américains avant
tout lors de cette conférence de presse
il a aussi estimé que vladimir poutine
et bien ne cherchez pas une guerre
froide avec les états unis
voilà ce que l'on peut retenir de cette
prise de parole du président américain
une prise de parole et bien qui a conclu
ce sommet entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui à genève stephan et
merci à olivier de queiros laquelle on
retrouve nos invités un bruno presque
yves pozzo di borgo et à théo l'eau
brillé à bruno bresse qui a on vient de
l'entente mois par la bouche de notre
reporter avait des fautes chine qui ne
cherche pas une guerre froide avec les
états unis nous non plus a répondu joe
biden on savait que les relations entre
les deux pays était au plus bas avant
aujourd'hui est ce que clairement il ya
un avant et un après cette seule
rencontre aujourd'hui sans doute alors
elle était au plus bas donc elle pouvait
difficilement descendre plus bas si ce
n'est qu' on allait vers une guerre ce
qui évidemment on était le souhait de
personnes et donc on peut dire que
aujourd'hui on a stabilisé les choses et
que donc maintenant le les relations
sont à un niveau disons ou la sécurité
globale semble devoir être garanti les
les négociations reprennent les
ambassadeurs s'échangent et le lot
l' équilibre des armements va être sans
doute travailler dans les deux relais
dans les mois qui suivent revanche
évidemment on ne pouvait pas s'attendre
à des miracles c'est à dire que la
situation entre la russie et les
etats-unis et plus largement la russie
et les pays occidentaux sont descendus
tellement bas que il s'agissait donc de
restaurer si je peux dire une confiance
minimum mais évidemment on est loin de
d'aller vers ce qu'on aurait pu appeler
une détente
parce que ça ne peut pas se faire en un
jour et puis effectivement nous sommes
dans un monde multipolaire et
aujourd'hui la russie est bien sûr
important dans ce monde d'autres
puissances émergentes le sont aussi
et fondamentalement la question centrale
c'est effectivement le rapport entre la
chine et les états unis et dans ce
contexte là les russes ont bien prévu
avant les événements qu'il n'allait pas
rompre avec la chine pour se rapprocher
de l'occident mais en même temps il
voulait stabiliser les rapports avec
l'occident
mais la météo le brillant nos deux
invités uns parlent tous deux de la
chine est effectivement qui était
manifestement sur toutes les lèvres
surtout en coulisses on offre comme on
dit dans le jargon des des journalistes
mais ni l'un ni l'autre n'a parlé
officiellement en tout cas de la chine
lors des deux conférences de presse
toute façon je moi je pense
personnellement que ce sommet c'était
avant tout un sommet pour l'image que
finalement peu de choses concrètes en
sont sortis si ce n'est le retour d
ambassadeur américain en russie russo
était cependant je pense
qu'effectivement la chine est dans
toutes les têtes et la russie n'est pas
vraiment une
une priorité pour les états unis puisque
la russie ne menace pas le leadership
américain et c'est d'ailleurs l'élément
central du voyage de joe biden en europe
c'est de rétablir le leadership
américain qu'il estime avoir été
souillées entre guillemets par donald
trump durant son mandat
je crois que de ce côté là joe biden a
réussi que ce soit au g7
à l'otan et cette rencontre même si on
n'en tire pas grand chose aura au moins
permis ou deux hommes de se rencontrer
s'étaient déjà rencontrés mais à
l'époque joe biden était vice président
des états unis donc n'avait pas les
mêmes eux mêmes fonctions disons est
bénigne ont très certainement été tracée
entre les deux pays pour qu' il n'y ait
pas de montée des tensions dans les
années où les mois qui viennent yves
pozzo di borgo une rencontre qu'elle
peut-être servi à rien mais non pas une
chanson un infléchissement depuis
l'époque
obama ou o'bama retraités la russie de
deux puissances régionales on s'en
souvient là on parle quand même sur un
même pied d'égalité ce qu'à dieu quand
même rassuré d'être des meilleures
poutines oui c'est tout c'est vrai que
la russie aux dépens de la russie
notamment après les années 2000 enfin
après année alcide
son problème c'est poutine qui l'a
exprimé c'était d'apparaître aussi comme
un partenaire des états unis vont c'est
une grande puissance
l'union soviétique et c'est vrai que
c'était tous leurs problèmes
l'affaiblissement des états unis
dépendant de la russie soit le signer
j'étais tout le travail qu'a fait
poutine mais je pense que s'ils
voulaient le temps donne je pense que
c'est aujourd'hui plus je vais le jeune
homme là qui parlent et se dire je
n'aime pas trop chez les verts est tt a
raison de le dire mais je crois que
c'était quand même aujourd'hui quelque
chose de qui va être très important pour
la suite mais très important pour la
suite
il ya un état d'esprit qui s'est créé
les problèmes ne sont pas réglés
tout à fait d'accord je jeu confort ce
que dit monsieur le président le
professeur de l'inalco mais je crois
qu'il ya d'état d'esprit qui serrés qui
s'est imposée et qui va d'après moi
aussi reggae l'union européenne parce
que l'union européenne c'est un petit
peu le petit roquet contre contre la
russie accompagnant un petit peu ce que
les états unis là je crois qu'il va y
avoir un changement d'attitude là je
crois que c'est quelque chose
d'important mais moi je continue à
penser que cette affaire de chine et
vous l'avez soulevées par le professeur
du nalco et il a fait la plus importante
on le voit d'ailleurs très bien parce
que le président chinois alors tout ça
évidemment pas confidentiel mais c'est
pas dans la presse mais du président
chinois à chaque fois qu'il voit un
responsable européen
qu'est-ce-qui
dit il dit mais pourquoi vous êtes
toujours avec les américains a passé des
accords avec nous et on l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs à l'otan qu est ce qu a réagi
d'ailleurs je pense que le poste d'un
maquereau est sensible à cet argument il
sait très bien qu'il veut pas changer
mais le président ma croix dans l'otan
il a bien quand même dit les choses
il a dit attendez l'otan c'est
attentiste le temps c'est pas pour le
monde entier et c'est là où on voit très
bien qu'il ya une offensive notamment de
2 des américains avec leur secrétaire
général a fait d'autant qu'ils étaient
keita catalogue qui cherche à amener
l'otan à être si vous voulez la grande
puissance militaire contre la chine
alors derrière tout ça aussi il faut je
passe devant le professeur venaco qu'il
maîtrise mieux que moi ce genre de chose
il faut savoir que parce que les
américains ont la puissance militaire
ils ont si la puissance du dollar et
c'est vrai que si la puissance militaire
s'affaiblit hyper de dollars et que dans
la grande bagarre qui s'annonce entre la
chine et les états unis
il ya aussi la bagarre de celui qu'elle
sera la monnaie mondiale est ce que ça
sera toujours dollars ce qui permet
d'ailleurs aux états unis 2 2 tous les
jours de faire fonctionner la planche à
billets est ce qu'un truc complètement
fou et la question qui se pose
maintenant c est ce que la chine va
réussir dans quelques années à imposer
notre monnaie et donc la casse et la
puissance américaine
je crois si ce débat qui sont en germe
dans tout cela mais ce que je retiens
moi c'est que vraiment c'était très
positif
cette rencontre et que je crois que
aussi bien pour l'union européenne que
pour tout le monde fait pour le monde
occidental c'est quelque chose de
positif
vous restez avec mon messieurs si vous
le voulez bien on va aller faire à
nouveau un détour vers genève on va
retrouver notre envoyé spécial antoine
clairon qui lui a particulièrement suivi
l'allocution de vladimir poutine
antoine gayraud
une tonalité que son homologue américain
une rencontre jugée constructive
oui tout à fait une rencontre jugée
constructive et positive et d'ailleurs
ça a démarré dès la première question de
cette conférence de presse de vladimir
poutine à savoir le retour de son
ambassadeur c'est il s'agit d'une mesure
tout à fait concrète et un pas en avant
dans ses relations entre les etats-unis
et la russie et s'était d'ailleurs
considéré comme un avancement une
avancée significative de voir ces
ambassadeurs revenir à leur poste ça
c'est ce qu'ont pensé en amont de cette
de cette de ce sommet d'aujourd'hui et
c'est donc maintenant chose faite les
ambassadeurs ont récupéré leurs postes
d'ici quelques jours vous propose
d'écouter vladimir poutine
c
pour des ambassadeurs à leur place
habituelle de travail à moscou et à
washington
nous nous sommes convenus que cette
question est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
l'horreur ambassadeurs respectifs demain
ou après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministère russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain
ils vont entamer des consultations sur
l'ensemble de notre interaction dans les
relations diplomatiques pour déblayer
tous les problèmes j'ai eu l'impression
que les deux parties vont essayer de
trouver des solutions que vladimir
poutine qui s'est également longuement
exprimé sur le sujet de la cyber
sécurité
un sujet où il existe de véritables que
de véritables possibilités de
coopération d'après lui est la preuve
avec des consultations au plus haut
niveau qui vont être organisées entre la
russie et les etats unis écouter
concernant la cybersécurité nous avons
convenu d'entamer des consultations à ce
sujet c'est selon moi extrêmement
important maintenant qu'ils devraient
prendre quelle obligation
je veux vous informer de choses qui sont
généralement connus mais pas par le
grand public
de source américaine j'ai juste peur de
me tromper dans le nom de l'organisation
mais peskov vous le transmettra plus
tard il ressort de source américaine que
le plus grand nombre de cyber attaques
dans le monde sont effectués à partir du
cyberespace américain en deuxième place
se trouve le canada puis il y a deux
pays d'amérique latine et enfin la
grande bretagne
la russie ne fait pas partie de cette
liste de pays à partir desquels le plus
grand nombre de cyber attaques de toutes
sortes sont effectués comme vous pouvez
le constater c'est la première chose
deuxièmement en 2020 nous avons reçu dix
demandes des etats-unis concernant des
cyber attaques visant des
infrastructures américaines comme le
disent nos collègues depuis le
cyberespace russe et il y a deux
demandes de ce genre cette année à
toutes ses demandes
l'année dernière et cette année nos
collègues ont reçu des réponses
exhaustives à son tour la russie a
envoyé 45 demandes de ce type à
l'organisation concernés aux états unis
l'année dernière et au premier semestre
de cette année 35
nous n'avons reçu pour l'instant aucune
réponse le crâne a également été un
sujet largement évoquée entre les deux
hommes l'ukraine est la ligne rouge que
constituerait pour le kremlin une
adhésion de ce pays à l'otan mais aussi
le conflit qui perdure dans l'est du
pays et pour vladimir poutine il y
existe il n'existe qu'une seule solution
c'est la mise en oeuvre totale et
complète des accords de minsk et
d'ailleurs il a d'ailleurs fait savoir
lors de cette conférence de presse que
joe biden était d'accord avec lui sur ce
point l'écouté concernant dans un
cauchemar vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
nous avons un seul engagement contribuer
à la réalisation des accords de mise
comme si que la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire on va entamer cette
voie sans aucun doute je porte votre
intention sur le fait que novembre
dernier la délégation ukrainienne nous a
adressé
et estimations sur sa leur vision des
accords de minsk
il parle de l'intégration politique du
temps basse dans le système politique
ukrainien et dans la constitution
ukrainienne a donc il faut apporter des
amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne
alors bien entendu de nombreuses autres
thématiques ont été abordées comme
l'arctique où la question des droits de
l'homme ou encore la sphère navalni un
sujet qui a fait qui a été la question
de plusieurs questions ont été posées
sur ce sujet par les journalistes
américains et britanniques
et à chaque fois venir poutine a répondu
de la même façon à savoir que il
dénonçait le fait que l'organisation d'
alexeï navalni appelé à des
manifestations interdites est appelé en
particulier des mineurs ce qui est
illégal en russie alors de façon
générale on peut retirer
il ressort de ce de ce sommet que il y à
un dialogue une possibilité de dialogue
entre les états unis et la russie sur de
très nombreux ce jeu de très nombreux
sujets alors il n'y a pas d'hostilité il
n'y a pas eu de deux mots plus haut que
les autres durant cette rencontre même
si bien entendu il reste de nombreuses
divergences sur bien des sujets mais
pour beaucoup
on espère qu'il s'agit d'une première
étape et d'une nouvelle étape dans les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis et antoine une dernière petite
question rapidement les journalistes ou
une remarque plutôt les journalistes
russes n'étaient pas conviés à la
conférence de presse de tourbe aidan
oui tout à fait c'est même une situation
qui a quelque peu indigné certains de
mes de mes confrères russes présents
autour de moi le fait que
l'administration l'administration
américaine n'est invité aucun
journaliste russe à la conférence de
presse de joe biden au contraire de la
conférence de presse de vladimir poutine
lors de laquelle de très nombreux de
très nombreux journalistes occidentaux
ont pu interpeller le président russe et
parfois même sur des questions délicates
on se rappelle en particulier d'une
journaliste qui a relancé le le
président russe en lui disant mais
monsieur poutine vous n'avez pas répondu
à ma question s'il vous plaît
recommencer et donc voilà c'est juste un
exemple pour pour un exemple de
questions délicates auxquelles il a fait
il a fait face des questions très dures
sur des accusations des accusations
graves des accusations d'ingérence même
d'assassinât mais rien de tout ça de
l'autre côté au niveau de la conférence
de presse de johnny hallyday nous
c'était beaucoup plus policé sans
aspérité merci antoine gayraud en direct
de genève rester avec nous dans quelques
instants on se retrouve pour parler de
cette rencontre inédite entre joe medan
et vladimir poutine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
dans toutes les entreprises du cac 40
ont perçu des aides publiques et une
très grande majorité a et va verser des
dividendes à ses actionnaires
ont-ils profité du système où le système
les at il un peu aidés ou verse des
aides à des gens qui n'en ont pas besoin
c'est pas la première fois que l'état
fait des choses idiotes
c'est édifiant mais c'est pas illégal si
vous commencez à verser des subventions
à certains secteurs économiques induits
sectorielle et pas un autre
il ya ce qu'on appelle un rupture
d'équité d'égalité le fait est qu on
aurait très bien pu mettre des
conditions mais qu'on savait de toute
façon c'était pas tenable vous pouvez
pas prêter de l'argent à une boîte en
faillite comme air france et lui dire
mais si je te prête de l'argent tu ne
peux pas censier du du personnel ça ne
tient pas debout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure de paris soyez les bienvenus
édition spéciale consacrée donc à cette
rencontre inédite entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine une rencontre qui a été
constructive il n'y avait aucune
animosité voilà comment vadimir poutine
a résumé cet entretien avec son
homologue américain même son de cloche
du côté de joe biden qui évoque une
tonalité je cite positive avant cette
rencontre les relations étaient pourtant
au plus bas entre washington et moscou
après 3h30 entrevue les deux dirigeants
ont tenu séparément une conférence de
presse ce soir et on va tout de suite
retrouvé en direct de genève notre
envoyé spécial olivier de kerzellec
bonsoir bonsoir même olivier vous vous
trouvez en compagnie de gabriel galice
président de l'institut international de
recherche pour la paix à genève et vous
allez donc les interviewés sur cette
rencontre et avoir son analyse
oui effectivement
stéphanie avoue lisier l'une des choses
qu'on retient ce soir c'est que cette
rencontre est bien malgré des
divergences
elle s'est déroulée sans une hostilité 1
c'est ce qu'ont souligné les deux chefs
d'état ce soir à l'issue de ce sommet
alors on va en parler avec vous un
docteur gabriel galice merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ici à genève alors finalement cette
rencontre elle était utile il semble que
oui on l'a déjà dit mais il est toujours
utile de se parler pour lever les
équivoques et puis se connaître déjà
parce que ils s'étaient déjà rencontrés
dans le passé mais pas dans leurs
fonctions actuelles
visiblement le premier contact semble
avoir été positif je vous invite à vous
tourner vers la caméra pour nous
répondre sur cette question et
maintenant à quoi est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre dans les relations entre les
états unis et la russie
à côté il faudrait déjà que un certain
nombre de dossiers contentieux
ça pèse nous allons voir si c'est le cas
dans dans les semaines et mois qui
viennent les dossiers chauds et puis
dans un deuxième temps je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on s'oriente vers une
approche multilatérale des problèmes là
on était dans le bilatéralisme et vous
savez que la meilleure approche celle
approche multilatérale parce que le
monde ne se réunit pas autour de la
russie et les etats unis c'est à dire
que chacun doit parler aux autres
nations ce sont vous y serez tous
ensemble il faut qu' il faut qu'à l'onu
qui à l'assemblée qui a la prérogative
pour ces rencontres là se rencontrent
discutent de tous les thèmes des
conflits de la paire au 21ème siècle
quel l architecture de sécurité quels
sont les contentieux quels sont les
modes de régulation
quels sont les systèmes de défense
collective qui sont mis en place voilà
ce qui est à l'ordre du jour pour un
chercheur pour la paix en tout cas un
chercheur pour la paix finalement
comment est-ce qu'ils analysent les
paroles à la fois de joe biden et et de
vladimir poutine ce soir qui ont été
dites au aujourd'hui c'est une bonne
entrée en matière comme en dix ans en
suisse et à genève en particulier il
faut entrer en matière entrée en matière
c'est commencé à ouvrir les pages du
livre donc le l'entrée en matière est
positive
maintenant il faut donner du contenu à
la matière et il faut finaliser les
choses il faut aller au delà
est ce l'enjeu de l'étape suivante il
faut confirmer le premier pas qui a été
fait à genève
ça veut dire l'étape suivante est bien
intégré d'autres états dans les
discussions bien sûr ça veut dire qu'il
faut intégrer tout le monde et je pense
que l'onu et le forum approprié pour ça
il ya
un lot est sérieux il ya un certain
nombre d'autres organismes
mais l'onu est l'organisme qui doit
fédérer toutes les réflexions et tous
les partenaires pour éviter de rentrer
dans des jeux un petit peu biaisée de la
diplomatie bilatérale ce qu'on peut
noter aussi ce soir à l'issue de cette
rencontre et halliche et aussi de la
tournée européenne de joe biden s'est
finalement joe biden aujourd'hui il
parle en tête à tête avec le président
de la confédération russie ce qui ne
fait pas avec emmanuel macron par
exemple
il ne l'a pas rencontré en tête à tête
comment est ce que vous le comprirent
vous le vous le comprenez il l'a
rencontrée dans d'autres occurrences il
l'a rencontrée fontainebleau il l'a
rencontrée à brégançon
c'est positif mais je crois que ça n'a
pas débouché
je crois qu'il ya rien de tel que de
discuter plutôt avec les bosses
effectivement il y en a qui semble plus
décisif que d'autres dans ce jeu là et
ça pose la question là derrière de
l'union européenne et les états membres
de l'union européenne quel jeu joue t-il
et un certain nombre de dossiers là
derrière notamment nord stream 2 qui ont
fait apparaître des divergences au sein
de l'union européenne
donc maintenant il va falloir que tout
ça aille dans le bon sens et que tout le
monde il retrouve ses intérêts parce que
chaque état ses intérêts propres
c'est normal qu'un intec 1 et à défendre
ses intérêts s'ils doivent pas et
égoïstes ils doivent être négociées
doivent être complémentaires à ceux des
autres mais ils peuvent être divergents
et c'est la règle du jeu diplomatique
faire croire que les uns que les
intérêts sont naturellement convergence
et naïf
donc il ya des divergences on les
examine et on trouve des solutions pour
conclure votre regard sur le fait que
désormais bien il y à leur tour un des
ambassadeurs dans les capitales
respectives des les puissances et 1 une
belle avancée
bien sûr c'est le premier pas c'est le
premier pack qui doit être suivi et d'un
certain nombre d'autres
espérons qu'il ne tarde pas à venir
merci beaucoup docteur gabriel galice
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
en direct de genève je voudrais je le
rappelle vous êtes président de
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève mais voilà
stéphanie donc ici à genève et bien le
calme revient on n'entend plus les
sirènes qu'on a pu entendre tout au long
de la journée notamment ce matin à
l'arrivée du cortège des deux chefs
d'état et puis ce soir avant leur départ
les deux hommes qui se sont envolés qui
ont désormais quitté genève après ce
sommet inédit qui s'est déroulé à la
ville à la grange aujourd'hui c'est que
vous nous avez fait suivre merci merci à
vous infiniment olivier de kerran flec
et finit ce soleil de plomb voilà qui
tombait sur les têtes à genève et nous
retrouvons à nos invités à bruno bref qu
yves pozzo di borgo
théo lobry bruno dref ski olivier vient
d'en parler avec son invité un le seul
acte vraiment concret de la journée mais
comme c'est souvent le cas lors de ce
range en deux rencontres bilatérales
c'est vraiment le retour de ces
ambassadeurs respectifs samedi quoi tout
de même ça ça montre un certain progrès
dans la dans les relations
ça veut dire qu'elles se normalisent au
moins sur le plan formel ce qui est
quand même toujours un signe que que
l'on va se parler
désormais et que je dirais les rapports
de force ayant été établie chacun sait
ce qu'il peut et ce qu'il ne peut pas et
qu'à partir de ce moment là on passe le
choses sérieuses on repasse aux choses
sérieuses alors ça ouvre une porte on
est loin d'arriver à des termes on ouvre
des portes et je pense pas ce qui est
évidemment aussi important à prendre en
compte que la russie ce qui fait la
force de la russie c'est que le monde et
multilatérales multipolaire entre les
deux puissances dont on a parlé
eh bien il ya des puissances émergentes
où des puissances revenante dans le cas
de la russie plus tôt et pour la russie
je pense qu'il est important aussi elle
a cherché l'émergence d'autres
puissances un peu partout dans le monde
je pense que ce que la russie aussi
souhaiterait c'est que les pays
européens deviennent un peu plus
indépendant et autonome pour renforcer
le multilatéralisme
[Musique]
données en quelques centres aussi à la
russie son rôle à jouer donc on les je
dirais les jeux sont ouverts maintenant
et on verra ce qu'il en a ce qu'il en
adviendra mais disons on est sorti de la
période de tension maximum à terme oui
théo lobry vous vous êtes un spécialiste
des états unis on sait que cette
rencontre était très observée depuis des
les etats-unis ont de joe biden et
vladimir poutine elle avait d'ailleurs
été déjà critiqué avant même d'avoir
lieu dans les rangs démocrates
votre opinion vous avez l'impression que
joe by dane a fait le job face à
vladimir poutine et que ça sera bien
accueillie du côté des états unis
oui bah je pense qu'il a fait il a fait
ce qu'il fallait et que aux états unis
on retiendra de lui qu son voyage en
europe s'est bien déroulée et que
surtout il a rétabli ce que je disais
tout à l'heure le leadership américain
et je le répète mais ce sommet c'est
avant tout à un sommet pour l'image et
aussi pour oublier le sommet d'helsinki
ou trump s'était comporté de façon
surprenante disons avec bladi remis avec
vladimir poutine
ce que les américains avaient assez mal
vécue enfin du moins une partie des
américains
merci théo lobry vous restez avec nous
tous les trois messieurs si vous le
voulez bien on va justement allé poser
la question à washington à notre
reporter thomas abonnés qui a eu
certainement les premières réactions des
américains thomas alors comment
ont été accueillis ces conférences de
presse et cette rencontre bilatérale
entre les deux hommes du côté de
washington
mais finalement vous savez stéphane il
ya toujours les mêmes critiques c'est à
dire que les républicains critiquent qui
critiquait déjà la tenue de ce sommet
continuent à le critiquer en expliquant
que joe biden a fait preuve de faiblesse
envers vladimir poutine
et puis les démocrates peut poursuivre
la rhétorique qui est celle de joe biden
à savoir celle d'un président qui a osé
aborder les sujets difficiles avec
vladimir poutine voilà pour les
premières réactions qu'on a ici faut
noter aussi qu'il ya eu pas mal de
réactions suite à la conférence de
presse qui vous l'avez dit était plutôt
policé mais à la toute fin de cette
conférence de presse de joe biden il y a
eu une sorte de passe d'armes entre joe
biden est une journaliste de cnn avec
des échanges assez ferme entre les deux
au point même que joe biden sa a
présenté ses excuses lorsqu'il était sur
le tarmac avant de monter sur pau dans
l'avion présidentiel pour le ramener aux
états unis voilà pour ce qui a aussi
retenu l'attention et puis toute la
journée ici les médias américains ont
analysé tous les faits et gestes des
deux présidents pour tenter d'y voir une
forme d' analyse d'ivoire des messages
un peu cachée avec parfois un peu un
manque d'honnêteté notamment on a vu des
journalistes de cnn faire des captures
d'écran de certaines des scènes qui se
sont déroulées aujourd'hui à genève avec
notamment une photo qui a été publiée on
voit la poignée de main entre vladimir
poutine et joe biden et journalistes
expliqué que le valdimir poutine
détourner le regard ou encore lorsqu'il
y avait cette scène ouverte à la presse
dans la ville à la grande île et bien il
y avait un journaliste qui a dit que
vladimir poutine n'y a pas de sourire
dans cette salle que l'ambiance était
pesante alors qu'en réalité lorsqu'on
voyait l'intégralité des images
finalement on se rendait compte que les
choses étaient très différentes mais
cela correspond bien aux la rhétorique
qui est utilisé par les médias
américains les médias mainstream qui
vous le savez sont globalement très
clément avec joe biden leur traitement
est radicalement différent pour ce
sommet organisé cette fois ci entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine que lors de
celui organisé entre donald trump et
vladimir poutine en 2018 est elle si qui
vous propose de regarder cet extrait
justement cette compilation des
différences de traitement des médias
américains le président biden essai
être non seulement la voix la plus forte
contre l'autoritarisme dans le monde
mais également le meilleur exemple de la
raison pour laquelle le modèle
autoritaristes et défaillances il ne
s'agit pas de conclure des accords mais
de fixer les limites avec la russie
selon mbaye donné ses conseillers
l'objectif est de regarder poutine droit
dans les yeux vous venez d'assister à ce
qui est sans doute la pire prestation
d'un président des états unis lors d'un
sommet face à un dirigeant russe
ce que je n'ai jamais vu une conférence
de presse hors du commun
je pense que les américains n'ont encore
jamais vu de conférence de presse de la
sorte entre un président américain et un
dirigeant russe décrit par tous nos
alliés comme un adversaire est un
adversaire dangereux
c'est d'ailleurs pour éviter les
critiques des médias américains qui
avaient lieu en 2018 que les équipes de
la maison blanche ont pris le soin de ne
pas participer ne pas faire participer
que joe biden à une conférence de presse
conjointe avec vladimir poutine parce
qu'évidemment donald trump ou l'avez
entendu avait été très vivement
critiquée à l'époque voilà en tout cas
le voyage de joe biden en europe touche
déjà à sa fin
joe biden qui va devoir revenir aux
affaires internes des états unis avec
quelques difficultés qui l'attendent et
d'ailleurs les journalistes n'ont pas
hésité à lui poser quelques questions
sur le tarmac justement sur des affaires
internes et joe biden va devoir vite y
revenir merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et on en parle est un petit
peu en parmi les rencontres officielles
qui ont réuni des dirigeants américains
et russes certains n'ont marqué les
esprits plus que d'autres retour en
images sur quelques uns de ces moments
clés de l'histoire géo politique
mais
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
m
et
on
non
[Musique]
on
m
mais
on va la pensée rencontres précédentes
yves pozzo di borgo l'attelage poutine
byden ça laisse présager quoi comme
comme relation ça avait débuté de
manière très sévère on se souvient bill
dann traitant vladimir poutine de deux
tueurs finalement ça va être circulez ya
rien à voir ça va plutôt bien se passer
à l'avenir selon vous c'est pour ça peut
classics et ces tensions notamment mais
je crois que si vous permettre là vous
avez fait référence à l'union soviétique
et je crois c'est la phrase de reagan
qui disait qu'il y avait des grandes
puissances le rss est là et des états
unis
le rapport de force a changé éliminant
le l'arsenal nucléaire ou les deux pays
contrôlent 90% de l'arsenal nucléaire
éliminant le chrono le port de fort
simplement otan russie il faut savoir
que le rapport de force
otan russie est pratiquement de 10,1
c'est à dire que l'otan une puissance
qui est il un incontestable à l'égard de
la russie
et ce qui fait que la communication d
europe et la communication des
américains ont des styles aussi caresser
pas vrai la russie a des missiles à 15
km de chez saint pétersbourg qu'ils ont
vu thi menace la russie c'est pareil
pour également pour l'heure les cyber
attaques
quand vous pensez que la nes a déjà il
ya 15 20 ans et côté tout le monde nous
nos présidents français sont écoutés par
l'ambassade américaine ce qui est pas le
cas d'un ambassadeur us qui écoute les
présidents français quand vous pensez
qu'à les gaffes à la puissance des
américains était incontestable par
rapport à ce que tu as russie
et c'est vrai que la communication qui a
derrière tout ça c'est à dire la russie
agresseurs je crois qu'il est bien il
faut bien prendre conscience que la
russie est à une puissance moyenne
elle a de quoi se défendre mais sur
toute la grande puissance et quand même
des états unis on n'est plus dans
l'union soviétique à la russie je crois
qu'il faut bien prendre qu'on peut tenir
compte de ces changements de rapports de
force qui est important et voilà je
voulais dire çà et là juste pour alors
pris pendant votre question je pense que
c'est quand même très positif et que
j'espère que l'état d'esprit qui s'est
installée malgré l'état profond
américain malgré les journalistes
américains car est pas d'en rajouter
enfin ils nourrissent français aussi
d'ailleurs européen malgré cela je pense
que ça a été quand même une journée qui
est quand même fondamental pour le bon
état d'esprit de l'union européenne de
la russie de la
2 les états unis et du monde en général
et à propos de journalistes à yves pozzo
di borgo le président russe a réagi aux
accréditations non reçus par les médias
au château des écoutes nick écouter des
meilleures poutines à ce sujet les
chouchous des yeah ethniques qui ont été
privé d'accréditation et c'était la
mesure de rotation de la part de la
russie tandis que roche ou day rempli de
toutes les exigences des autorités
américaines sur le territoire américain
quoique il ya toutes sortes d'obstacles
de nature financière par exemple nous
n'avons pas cette sorte de problèmes et
les médias américaines ne respecte
pleinement les exigences étaient sept au
virus quand même mais j'espère qu'on va
réussir grâce à notre ministère des
affaires étrangères de le faire et théo
lobry c'est un combat perdu d'avancé
selon vous qu on veut perdu devant sutil
espère que ces relations vont se
normaliser effectivement vis-à-vis des
médias russes ça reste compliqué ce sera
très certainement compliquées
effectivement après je n'ai pas les
tenants et les aboutissants et comment
est ce que les équipes de la maison
blanche du président byden pourquoi en
fait elles ont refusé l'accréditation
peut-être qu'on le saura un petit peu
plus tard par le biais d'articles ou ou
deux journalistes américains qui
donneront quelques détails mais aussi
revenir sur un point
effectivement les médias américains
notamment ceux de la côte est sont pro
démocrate on voyait des extraits de la
messe nbc hbo et mais samedi c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus pro démocrates aux
états unis
c'est un peu l'équivalent troc cios mais
les versions démocrate
mais je trouve que faire la comparaison
entre helsinki et genève est malvenue
donald trump à helsinki fait confiance à
vladimir poutine plutôt qu'à ses agences
de renseignement alors même qu'il a la
main sur ces agences de renseignement on
va imaginer imaginer n'importe quel
autre président européen qui du jour au
lendemain
désavoue cesser ses propres ses propres
soldats entre guillemets on pourrait
même dire comme ça le scandale que ça
peut faire ça aurait fait le même
scandale à peu près partout donc je
pense que les médias américains à
l'époque on pas exagérer la chose donald
trump a paru d'ancêtres danser dans ce
sommet d'helsinki être un petit peu une
marionnette alors dans son style
effectivement et c'est quelque chose qui
est très mal passée et donc le sommet de
genève aujourd'hui était un sommet est
plus classique on n'a pas une
extravagance de parts et d'autres
et je pense que le traitement médiatique
entre helsinki et genève n'est pas tout
à fait comparable
le mot de la fin pour vous bruno devrait
ce qu'ils veulent
tine qui parler voilà deux noms
hostilités volonté de nous comprendre
dialogue constructif c'est clairement ce
qu'on retiendra de de cette journée qui
était malgré tout un pape plutôt
important oui je pense que c'était un
pas important alors maintenant je pense
que bouquinales à bien marquer le point
parce qu'il a répondu à toutes les
attaques dont il a été l'objet lui
évidemment la russie il a montré sa
combativité donc le fait que battant
sera pris hier un rapport de forces est
disons diplomatiquement le rapport de
force il a réussi à le rétablir même si
comme cela a été dit le rapport de force
russie otan et 13 en défaveur de la
russie mais sur le plan je dirais de
l'image sur le plan de la
de la réponse sur les dossiers sensibles
droits de l'homme droit de la presse et
caetera
je pense que finalement poutine a été
assez habile pour qu'on puisse passer
aux choses sérieuses et à dire là où en
plus entendre on tentera pas sur ces
questions qui est évident que je viens
de mentionner mais on peut s'entendre
sur les questions de déséquilibres
militaire de diplomatie de
multilatéralisme et c est donc sur ce
plan là je pense que les choses vont
aller de l'avant rapt petite conclusion
peut-être avec un vous il faut se dit
borgo venir poutine qui a dit que
c'était une discussion franche et
directe
soulignant que ce n'était pas une
compétition mais vous savez bien comme
moi on observe toujours s'il y a un
gagnant et un perdant qui s'est le plus
distingué qui ressort le plus avantagé
et gagnant de cette rencontre est de ces
deux conférences de presse selon vous
non non je crois que c'est la vérité je
crois qu'il ya eu ces 7 contre cette
rencontre a été un élément de ou en fait
chacun dit ce qu'il avait à dire et je
pense pas qu'il puisse y avoir un
gagnant et un perdant je crois que
c'était très positif et le posant
poutine a été comme il est le président
biden n'oubliez pas que le président
wade n a été tout jeune président de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat c'était une puissance
extraordinaire et qu'il avait de très
bons rapports à l'époque avec les
dirigeants soviétiques c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît les coûts de ces l'union
soviétique il connaît la russie et c'est
pour ça que quand il ya eu les premières
escarmouches entre poutine et bidache
dit bon ça va pas durer
parce qu'il connaît très bien ce rapport
de forces sur la vie aujourd'hui
en fait c'est cette signification l'a
bien vu que ça on avait deux présidents
qui avaient envie si vous les deux n'ont
pas terrible épreuve du jour au
lendemain mais d'engager d'état d'esprit
différent dans le rapport merci beaucoup
à tous les trois bons noms bref qu yves
pozzo di borgo et théo lobry d'avoir été
avec nous merci également à nos
reporters sur le terrain et aux équipes
techniques et c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale prochain point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée avec
nadège abderrazak à 22h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre fonction c'est évidemment